Os voy a contar una historia.
Os voy a contar la historia de Aryan:
una de las mujeres más valientes
que he conocido jamás.
La conocí en Kobané, una ciudad
asediada en el norte de Siria,
y decidí seguirla con mi cámara.
Con ella he vivido las experiencias
más bestias que he vivido en la vida.
La guerra es difícil de explicar;
en la guerra no hay ayer ni mañana;
en la guerra solo hay aquí y ahora.
Y la vida se vive con intensidad,
porque mira de frente a la muerte.
Nunca había visto tanta gente muerta;
quizá por eso nunca me había
sentido tan viva.
Aryan en kurdo significa "fuego".
Este es un nombre de guerra y le fue
dado cuando se hizo guerrillera,
hace muchos años.
Ahora Aryan es una de
las comandantes de las YPJ:
las Unidades de Defensa de las
Mujeres; un ejército de mujeres
que ha tomado el control de la
zona kurda del norte de Siria.
Con Aryan fui parte de una operación
que puso fin al asedio de Kobané
y juntas celebramos la victoria;
fue muy emocionante.
Pero juntas, también lloramos
la muerte de amigas;
de demasiadas.
La muerte nos pisaba los talones,
pero Aryan nunca miraba atrás.
Me gustaba observarla: siempre energética,
organizando las tropas con voz firme.
Aryan tiene 33 años y cuando tenía 18,
decidió que ya estaba harta
de la injusticia que veía a su alrededor.
Se alistó a un ejército de mujeres
para defender sus derechos
y los de todas las mujeres.
Aryan quería ser libre y escogió
el camino más radical:
el de las armas.
Si no nos protegemos nosotras,
¿quién lo hará?,
me dice siempre.
Aryan creció en Afrin,
una ciudad kurda al norte de Siria.
Cuando tenía 12 años fue testigo
de un crimen horrible:
un grupo de hombres, en su barrio,
violaron a una niña de su edad.
Esta quedó embarazada
y su familia la asesinó
para proteger su honor.
Desde entonces Aryan está decidida
a cambiar la realidad de las mujeres
que tiene a su alrededor;
cueste lo que cueste.
Mientras habla de feminismo,
con las chicas más jóvenes,
las soldados más jóvenes, en el frente.
a pocos metros del frente enemigo,
mientras cae algún mortero,
me doy cuenta de que su lucha,
como mujer, como mujer guerrera,
es doble: ella está luchando
contra el Estado Islámico,
pero a la vez está librando
una batalla muy dura
contra su sociedad.
"No pararemos hasta que
acabemos con el patriarcado",
decía siempre Aryan.
Y ¡boom!, caía un mortero
a 50 metros de nosotras.
Acabar con el patriarcado, acabar
con los 5000 años de patriarcado
que han definido las relaciones
sociales y económicas
en casi todo el mundo
es un proyecto ambicioso;
muy ambicioso.
Pero también lo era acabar
con la esclavitud,
que todavía era legal
en Mauritania en 1980.
O acabar con la segregación racial,
que sigue existiendo hoy,
pero solamente en Israel.
Para cambiar el mundo hay
que creer en lo imposible.
¡Boom! Otro mortero.
"No tengas miedo" me decía Aryan;
es muy difícil que te caiga
un mortero en la cabeza.
Cuando se acerca un mortero se oye:
"tsch, tsch, tsch", como si fuera
un helicóptero pequeño;
entonces, tienes que tirarte al suelo.
Un mortero cuando cae, antes de explotar,
se levanta medio metro,
y si estás en el suelo, aunque caiga
cerca de ti, no te va a matar.
"Lo que te tendría que dar miedo
son las minas" me decía siempre.
"Vas caminando con el ojo pegado
a tu cámara,
y no miras dónde pisas".
Las minas son la principal causa
de muerte entre las compañeras;
hay minas por todas partes:
en las carreteras, en las aldeas,
que se liberaban... Algunas están
tan bien escondidas que sorprenden
a la soldado cuando abren una puerta,
o cuando cruzan un camino...
Otras explotan cuando
las intentan desactivar;
alguna soldado ha perdido una pierna,
otras han perdido un brazo;
las que han tenido suerte.
Algunas ya no están...
como Peyman o como Rojda...
Tenían 18 años cuando pisaron
la mina que las mató.
Las unidades de la defensa de la mujer
se crearon en Siria en el 2013 y están
formadas por unas 12 000 mujeres
de entre 18 y 40 años.
Junto con las unidades de defensa
del pueblo, formadas por hombres,
defienden unos ideales progresistas,
en oposición a las ideologías radicales
de los yihadistas.
Ellas, y ellos, defienden un nuevo
sistema político basado en la igualdad
de género, en la sostenibilidad
ecológica y en la democracia real.
Ellas son las protagonistas de
la primera revolución del mundo
que ha puesto a la mujer
en el centro de los cambios.
Por eso yo, como mujer, como mujer
cineasta, me siento orgullosa
de formar parte, de alguna forma,
de esta revolución.
Aryan está pegando gritos otra vez.
Nos pide que nos organicemos en
los vehículos porque hay que partir.
Vamos avanzando por las llanuras sirias;
a nuestro alrededor,
los campos de trigo arden.
Vamos siguiendo una decena
de coches medio destartalados.
Y vamos entre los campos porque
en los caminos hay minas.
El primero es un bulldozer, que
va circulando con la pala bajo,
por si hay alguna mina.
Le siguen unos cuantos pick-ups,
con los cristales agrietados,
una ambulancia vieja, con
las serigrafías en alemán,
y algunas furgonetas con los diseños
de camuflaje pintados a mano.
Parecemos sacados de
una escena de Mad Max.
Hoy es el primer día de la operación
para poner fin al asedio de Kobané.
La operación consiste en abrir un corredor
para unir Kobané con el resto
del Kurdistán de Siria.
Nosotras avanzaremos desde Kobané hacia
el este, y las tropas al otro lado
del cerco avanzarán hacia el oeste,
hasta que nos encontremos en Tel Abyad.
Kobané es una ciudad que lleva asediada
más de 2 años y se ha convertido
en el icono de la resistencia
en contra del Estado Islámico.
En el 2014, cuando las tropas de Daesh,
así se llama ahí el Estado Islámico,
estaban avanzando por el territorio sirio
sin encontrar la resistencia,
llegan a Kobané con la intención
de ocuparla.
Pero los kurdos no lo van a permitir.
Durante muchos meses se libra una batalla
muy sangrienta. Y, aunque los de Daesh
son mayores en número
y mucho más fuertes en armamento,
no consiguen vencer a los kurdos, que
luchan a muerte para defender su ciudad.
Finalmente la coalición internacional
interviene con bombardeos aéreos
y Daesh se retira; pero la ciudad,
a pesar de quedar en manos kurdas,
queda completamente destrozada
y asediada.
Aryan perdió muchas amigas
en esta batalla.
Una de ellas murió en sus brazos.
"Su recuerdo me da fuerzas para seguir
luchando", me dijo una vez.
Para ella acabar con el asedio de Kobané
es algo que debe no solo a la gente
que vive allí, sino a todas las amigas
que murieron defendiendo la ciudad.
Hace mucho calor. El pantalón militar
se me pega a la piel.
Aryan va vestida con la chaqueta
abrochada hasta el cuello
y con un pañuelo
Yo voy arremangada y me lo quitaría todo.
Pero en el frente hay que ir tapado.
Vamos avanzando por territorios
controlados por el Estado Islámico.
Llegamos a un pueblo árabe.
Las soldados separan
a los hombres de las mujeres
y arrestan a algún hombre sospechoso
de pertenecer al Estado Islámico.
Registran a las mujeres. Yo las observo.
Unas mujeres van tapadas con velos,
llevan vestidos largos.
Las otras llevan uniformes militares
y las Kalashnikov en la mano.
Qué destinos tan distintos,
los de estas mujeres.
Me pregunto en qué lado estaría yo,
si hubiera nacido en Siria.
Es de noche y montamos
el campamento en una aldea
Hay como unas siete casas construidas
con ladrillos de hormigón sin rebozar.
Las registramos una a una.
Son casas humildes, cubiertas
de cojines y alfombras,
con algún mueble viejo.
En las cocinas hay cazuelas
con arroz y pan recién horneado.
No hay nadie, pero todo está como si
fueran a volver en cualquier momento.
"No toquéis nada", nos dice Aryan.
Sacamos una alfombra muy grande
y varias mantas de nuestro pick-up
y nos instalamos en el tejado
de una de las casas.
Es una noche fresca y oscura, sin luna.
Dos chicas hacen guardia.
Estamos a pocos metros del frente
del Estado Islámico
y nos pueden atacar en cualquier momento.
Me duermo con el zumbido grave
de los aviones de guerra.
Me despierta una explosión.
Por la radio se oyen gritos
distorsionados y a lo lejos disparos.
Están atacando el campamento vecino,
y las chicas se han levantado,
y a toda prisa, con las Kalashnikov
en la mano,
corren escaleras abajo.
Yo las sigo con mi cámara.
¿Aryan, puedo venir?
Me dice que no.
Entonces, planto el trípode,
fuera, en la puerta,
para grabar la salida.
Y las chicas salen, se meten
dentro de la furgoneta,
la furgoneta arranca, y cuando todavía
está dentro del cuadro de mi cámara,
veo como Aryan baja la ventanilla,
saca el brazo,
y me hace señales para que vaya.
Las siguientes imágenes
son dentro de la furgoneta.
Yo, como es de noche, tengo el visor
nocturno de la cámara activado,
y lo veo todo verde.
Y así es como lo recuerdo, todo verde.
A medida que nos vamos acercando
al campo de batalla,
el estruendo de los disparos
es más fuerte.
Cuando llegamos, aparcamos
detrás de un muro.
Las chicas bajan, y todas nos
acercamos agachadas hacia una casa.
De ahí salen unos soldados kurdos
amigos, corriendo y nos dicen:
"¡Iros, iros!"
El Estado Islámico se está acercando.
Pero nosotras seguimos
avanzando hacia la casa.
Subimos las escaleras, y las chicas
montan trincheras, arriba, en el tejado.
Hay como unos 20 militantes
del Estado Islámico
que se acercan hacia nosotras.
Durante un buen rato,
hay un tiroteo cruzado.
Finalmente, los militantes
del Estado Islámico
se refugian en una casa parecida
a la nuestra, a unos 300 metros.
Entonces, Aryan llama al avión.
Lo hace con una aplicación
que tiene en el móvil,
que manda las coordenadas exactas.
Tres, dos, uno...
Una gran explosión que crea una nube
de polvo y humo delante de nosotras,
destrozando la casa
donde se habían refugiado
los militantes del Estado Islámico.
Así, 'boom' en un 'plis'.
Ni atenciones, ni juicios, ni cárcel.
Directamente al paraíso.
Aryan se queda un buen rato
mirando por los binoculares.
Lejos, en el campo, se ven cuerpos,
varios cuerpos.
"Están todos muertos", dice Aryan.
Lo dice sin alegrarse.
Ninguna mujer que conocí en Siria
se alegraba por la muerte del enemigo.
Mientras los chicos celebraban
la victoria,
ellas se quedaban sentadas,
perdidas en sus pensamientos.
"Estas muertes son una barbarie",
me dijo un día Aryan.
Se está matando en nombre del poder,
en nombre de la religión,
por pura violencia.
La relación de las mujeres con la guerra
es muy distinta a la de los hombres.
Para ellas, los sacrificios que tienen
que hacer, cuando se hacen soldados,
son mucho más duros que
los de un soldado regular.
Ellas tienen que ir en contra de todo
aquello por lo que han sido educadas.
Tienen que renunciar a casarse,
a la maternidad, a la familia.
Para Aryan, su familia son sus amigas.
Los lazos que tiene con ellas
son muy fuertes.
Hace muchos años que no ve a sus padres.
Ni siquiera a su hermano pequeño,
a Baran, que siguiendo sus pasos,
se alistó también a la guerrilla,
y aunque esté en el ejército, el asedio
de Kobané les ha tenido separados
hace también dos años.
Es de noche, y estamos en el campamento
y como está el generador
eléctrico encendido
las chicas más jóvenes han aprovechado
para ver su serie favorita
en el televisor.
Es una telenovela india de esas
que contienen todos los clichés
de género que os podéis imaginar.
Me chocaba mucho que les gustara
esa serie.
Aryan y yo estamos fuera.
Por la noche la temperatura baja
y nos podemos relajar del calor agobiante
que teníamos que soportar
durante el día.
"¿Has estado alguna vez enamorada?"
Le pregunto.
Me dice que sí.
Juntos nos alistamos al ejército
y nos prometimos mutuamente
que lucharíamos hasta el final.
Aryan no sabe si se volverán
a ver, pero no le importa.
Para ella, el amor no es casarse
y tener hijos.
Ella ha canalizado su amor hacia
toda su gente, hacia su pueblo.
"El amor no puede ser posesivo", me dice.
"El amor tiene que ser grande,
tienes que hacerlo crecer,
el amor hacia solo una persona,
puede matar el amor".
Con la salida del sol, seguimos avanzando.
Si conseguimos llegar a Tel Abyad,
habremos puesto fin al cerco que Daesh
mantiene alrededor de nosotras.
Vamos avanzando por pueblos fantasma.
En los tejados de algunas casas,
se ven las banderas negras
del Estado Islámico ondeando.
Pero los militantes no están.
Han huido, parece que se están retirando.
Al día siguiente seguimos avanzando,
estamos ya muy cerca de Tel Abyad.
A lo lejos, vemos la bandera kurda,
izada, ondeando.
Aparcamos y Aryan corre
a saludar a sus amigas.
Hace más de dos años que no se ven.
Es muy emocionante.
Aryan busca a su hermano entre
la multitud, pero no lo encuentra.
De repente, hay una alarma.
Unos coches no identificados se acercan,
y tememos que podrían ser
coches bomba suicida.
Nos metemos todas en los coches
corriendo y dejamos el lugar.
Era una falsa alarma, pero
nos hemos tenido que ir de ahí
sin que Aryan pudiera ver a su hermano.
Desde Tel Abyad, las tropas se coordinan
para entrar triunfalmente a Kobané.
Estamos celebrando el final del asedio,
gritando, cantando, disparando al aire.
Cuando llegamos a Kobané, toda
la población está en la calle.
Por fin el asedio que habían sufrido
durante dos años ha terminado.
Vamos circulando detrás de
un centenar de coches militares,
entre la ciudad,
o entre lo que queda de ella.
A nuestro alrededor todo son ruinas.
No hay ninguna casa en pie.
Cuando llegamos a la plaza principal,
toda la ciudad, es decir,
cientos de personas
celebrando la victoria.
De repente, veo a un chico alto y guapo
que se acerca hacia nosotras.
Cuando Aryan le ve, se abrazan
con una intensidad
que yo solamente había visto
en las películas.
Es Baran.
La fiesta continúa durante todo el día.
Al día siguiente me despierto tarde.
Las chicas ya están levantadas
y se están preparando para salir.
Yo me acerco a Aryan,
con un par de tazas de café, y le digo:
"Bueno Aryan, ahora nos podríamos tomar
unas vacaciones; nos podríamos ir
al río Éufrates, darnos
un bañito, relajarnos..."
Aryan se ríe.
Yo me pongo seria y le digo:
"No, no estoy bromeando. Llevamos más
de un mes en el frente, nos merecemos
unas vacaciones".
Aryan me mira y me dice:
"Para nosotras no hay final. Nosotras
hoy nos vamos hacia el sur".
En un par de horas
los pick-ups están listos
y Aryan se va con las tropas.
Nos despedimos sin mucho ritual:
"Hasta luego camarada Aryan".
Y mientras veo cómo se va,
me pregunto si nos volveremos a ver.
Hace unas semanas recibí
un mensaje de su hermano Baran,
me decía que Aryan había sido
gravemente herida,
y que la habían tenido
que evacuar en helicóptero,
y que la estaban operando
en un hospital en el norte de Irak.
No sabían si iba a sobrevivir.
Me costó muchos días averiguar
en qué ciudad estaba,
pero cuando me enteré fui para allá.
La encontré en un estado deplorable.
Cuando me vio, me miró y sonrió.
Yo tuve que hacer un esfuerzo
para contener la emoción
que me provocaba verla así.
Se incorporó con esfuerzo,
se levantó la camiseta,
y me enseñó sus heridas de guerra.
Una bala le atravesaba los pechos,
entrándole por el pecho izquierdo,
y saliéndole por el pecho derecho.
Otra bala le había destrozado el brazo,
el que utiliza para disparar.
Otra bala le había entrado por la nalga,
y le había salido por el ombligo,
destrozándole el sacro y afectando
de forma irreversible varios nervios
de la pierna.
Sentí mucha rabia.
¿En qué mundo vivimos que ha obligado
a toda una generación de mujeres a tener
que enfrentarse a la muerte para
defender su derecho a existir?
Pero Aryan parecía tranquila.
"La libertad por la que luchamos" me dijo,
"no es una libertad geográfica.
La libertad es interior, y una vez
alcanzada, no nos la puede quitar nadie".
Para Aryan, la libertad es un camino,
que se puede elegir seguir o no seguir.
Para Aryan, la libertad empieza
en una misma, y tiene que ver
con las decisiones conscientes
que tomamos cada día,
que nos conectan con quienes somos
realmente, con nuestra esencia,
que nos acercan a nuestros sueños.
Aryan sueña con un mundo en paz,
donde todas las mujeres de todo el mundo
puedan vivir en condiciones
de igualdad a los hombres,
donde puedan expresarse libremente,
donde puedan tomar decisiones
en su sociedad.
Aryan es consciente de que quizás
no podrá vivir para disfrutar de su sueño.
Ella lucha para las mujeres de mañana,
pero la realidad es que Aryan hoy
ya ha conseguido muchas cosas,
Aryan ya ha cambiado la realidad
de muchas mujeres a su alrededor.
Además, su lucha feminista,
sus acciones heroicas, su sacrificio,
está sembrando semillas que pueden
cambiar la realidad de muchas mujeres
en Oriente Medio,
y pueden inspirar cambios para cambiar
la realidad de mujeres en todo el mundo.
Aryan ya es libre, y lucha para
que todas mujeres puedan serlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)